orioles are 20 and 25 the yankees are 25
and 21. yankees complete the sweep and
boy
they could really put the orioles to bed
or take a big step toward doing that
so alberto is ready hat is ready let's
do it
lined right to lemayo one away so
iglesia is on with a hard-line single
and that will bring up the rookie ryan
mount castle
swing and a miss mount castle down on
strikes
here's severino 2-2 and the pitch is
pumped up
to shallow right estrada going out on
the grass makes the catch
and that will take care of the inning
john allen means from olathe kansas went
to junior college out of high school
eventually made his way to west virginia
where he was an 11th round pick
back in 2014. two outs nothing nothing
our score
bottom of the first and clint frazier
coming up
frazier drives one out to left center
mount castle and mullins coming in and
cedric mullins has got it
the second inning from yankee stadium on
sunday ronaldo nunez
steps in first renato nunez
sends one out to right field clint
frazier is at the wall
and frazier will watch this one go into
the first row
short porch bonanza ronaldo nunez goes
the other way in the bronx
his fifth home run in 22 career at bats
off of jhap here is tyler wade
who is 10 for 66 with a homer and four
rbis swung on and line to right field
and deep stewart back that ball is gone
over the wall into the right field seats
to tie the game
tyler wade made in the shade
he homers to right and the ball game is
tied at one if you give up a porch job
you expect one in return
tyler wade just got you tied back up the
yankee catcher kyle higashioka
is now the batter with the bases loaded
and just one out
and agashioka pops it up that could work
if it stays in play
and severino backpedaling will make the
catch
tyro has trotted two walks but 0 for
five in the series
and this one's popped up right side
heading towards no man's land
stored on the run now on foul ground and
he makes the catch
and john means leaves the bases loaded
runners lead first and second with one
out and here comes a 3-2 once again to
alberto
runners go again swung on the miss throw
to third
it's a strike him out throw him out
double play just like that the yankees
get out of
a first and third no out jam fifth
strikeout for half and the play goes
bring in jonathan holder first and
second
two outs this all happened with two outs
without avina a walking in a single 1-1
game and holder looks like he's done the
job
the mayu and foul territory makes the
play
that is tyler wade digs in there's a
home run back in the third inning
against john means
tyler wade floats one into center and
cedric
mullins with a superman effort
a one two three inning for dylan tate a
tremendous play
by cedric mullins in the outfield and
the side is retired
zach britton comes on for the yankees
and he will face the top of the order
starting with hansor alberto
chop the third oh what a play by lemayo
one down that was not an easy play
you see this play in a five to nothing
game you think wow great play but in a
one-to-one game
late in the game lead-off hitter even
more important
great job by le mayhew and they do bring
up glaiber torres the pinch hit for
gardner
big spot here for taurus swung on and
lined toward the alley in right center
it is a base hit one hop off the right
center field wall
hicks scores and rounding third frazier
the throw home
is not in time it is a
two-run pinch-it double by gleber torres
and the yankees take a 3-1 lead well
gleber torres has
really turned it up recently offensively
and aaron boone had no problem
sending him up in this situation after
getting behind in the count that
is the glaber torres that we've wanted
to see for a long time driving the ball
to right center field
not coming off the ball huge hit for the
yankees
two outs yankees up three to one in the
ninth inning the closer chapman on the
mound
and that will do it strike three
stewart down looking chapman works a one
two
three ninth and the yankees sweep the
orioles with a three to one victory that
man with his first
pinch hit in his career first rbi is a
pinch hitter in his career